he's a Nigerian billionaire and founder
of the dango tech group his company
operates in Nigeria and other African
countries he has an estimated net worth
of eighteen point six billion dollars
he's a leak o dangoty and here are his
top ten rules for success
well how to be a good leader you have to
be a very good listener you have to
listen to people you have to also listen
to quite a lot of advice you have to
make sure that it is not what you tell
people to do you have to you know crack
your brains and have quite a lot of what
you call advice from your own team you
know it has to be a team work because
there's no way you can make it as a
person without a good team you must be
consistent when you try a business and
you start you might have hiccups here
and there but it does not mean that that
business is not going to work there must
be challenges in fact what I keep saying
is that life without challenges is very
very boring so if you have challenges
you just have to know how to work out
how to work around these challenges I
will be successful once you are
consistent what business does it like is
for you to try something and then once
you have one or two problems and I want
to change and move into another business
that doesn't work in business actual
whether the data is you know you need to
have a lot of information at your
fingertips so that it will allow you to
make decisions and you need to also take
the right you know decisions what I was
doing five years ago if I try to do them
without the automation that we have
today it's just not going to happen at
all
well the problem will be some of our
younger generation today we just want to
jump and see themselves up there
overnight it doesn't really happen what
you need to do is to be very very
focused as a person and be dedicated to
whatever that you are doing it is not
really good for you to not wanna try
something then after a month you just
say no it doesn't work you jump into
something else I think you need to be
very very focused in what you are do
once you believe in what you are do you
see it should not take your either
business or job as something that you
must do okay you must take it as is part
of your hobby if it's hard to be a hobby
then you do it better you know you
always have to think ahead you know in
business sometimes what would be fun
would be much more so you need to you
know look at if you have the means
that's not only need like the
versification you know sometimes you do
quite a lot of diversification I mean
education and then you consolidate
before you move forward you cannot just
keep finding expanding because sometimes
what you go by expand is not possible
prices oceans so you need at least once
in a while to consolidate under you know
over when you look at you know it is
really not common for somebody to leave
banking I'm going to start something
totally new you know especially in an
area of Events Management because at the
time that she left the bank which was
ten years ago nobody thought that
something like events management will
actually succeed but I mean it is good
that is really what you call into
progressive and also a vision you know
she had a vision and she is able to
actualize our vision is just like myself
I remember one time I went to address a
retreat of First Bank of Nigeria and I
was a little fast back over Nigeria this
is where the good is going to be in the
next five years I mean there were not
really that big at the time that I went
there to address them and I'm sure you
know they couldn't really believe what I
was saying then but I remember at a
point the MG said that well you know
they are really shocked at how we
actually
being able to make it and also actualize
our vision so I think was this same that
she has done I passionately believe it
is just beginning of the journey because
she has a vision and I'm sure if she
continues to do this can turn into
another mega business you know because
like what I always say look for an
intrapreneur there are no boundaries not
only other no boundaries you can
actually excel much more than your own
expectation and that's really what I
expect of an intern or to be not to just
say okay fine I have a vision and only
achieve that your vision you need to
have a vision and a mission so that you
can actually actualize it and also excel
I mean I had somebody who came to
interview me one time and I told him
that yes you know three four five years
ago I never ever expected myself to be
on the Forbes list but right now the
vision that I have
and also my own mission is actually to
be on top of the light not even where I
am today and that's really how you know
a visionary person should be a hard walk
I've made that you know we're very
focused were very focused company we
don't really go into things that we
don't understand you know any business
that I don't understand it well I don't
do it actual and that's really well you
know
while we are successful to be an
entrepreneur and also to be a visionary
person you have to actually be very very
bold you have to be ready to take
calculated risk
not just any risk you have to take a
calculated risk and you have to think
big if you think small you always have
been small in life the way that we
operate as a company you know especially
in don't go t is like what I said we
have a vision the vision will have a
strategy of how we're going to achieve
the vision which we do normally over a
period of five years you know I mean
like today we know why we're going even
this investment that I announced or four
hundred million dollars here I didn't
just sit down on my own and just say it
it is part of our strategic plan to
invest in Kenya I mean to be serious if
you want to be the next dangoty is that
you have to have a very big heart you
have to take quite a lot of risk
calculated risk first of all you have to
make sure that you're honest you must
make sure that you don't destroy the
name you know because your name is very
important that the most valuable asset
that you have going for the way if you
don't have a good name even the banks
doesn't matter how big you are they're
not gonna touch each one so you must
make sure that I have a very very good
name and number three you have to make
sure that you see that look nothing is
impossible once you say that yes nothing
is impossible it means that you can
actually achieve that target thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because nari ABBA asked me to so there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of ilyich odango
these top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon